donc toutes les mamans, vous savez que ça
jouait pour vous aujourd'hui, si j'étais une
joueuse, je me mettrais à genoux tous
les soirs et je remercierais Dieu que
Roger Federer et un dur avec le diable
soient importants pour obtenir le  message
à nos jeunes hommes à nos
garçons à nos filles arrêtons ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je pense que ce que les gens ne réalisent pas, c'est à quel point
la violence n'affecte pas seulement votre
famille  mais vos amis, vos voisins,
tout le monde et je vais m'arrêter là.
J'ai eu honte de mon corps depuis que
je suis aux yeux du public. Je n'aimais pas
qui j'étais, mais en vieillissant, j'ai
compris que c'était méchant.  mon corps,
ça crée toutes ces opportunités
pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons eu beaucoup de complications mais regardez
ce que nous avons eu, j'ai une petite fille
[Musique]
Je l'appelle comme mon  je vais condor en spired
tu sais que c'est le catsuit
[Musique]
J'ai juste envie de dire à toutes les mamans si
je peux le faire, elles peuvent le faire, tu peux être
ce que tu veux être